hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one key dimension of franz finon's book
black skin white masks is what we can
call an interplay
or as he's going to say at several
points a dialectic
between what we can understand as the
universal
and the specific or particular and this
is taking place
in a number of different ways within the
work
so it's not always exactly the same
particular exactly the same universal
that we're
looking at and so we should think about
what what
the orientation the
self-description of unknown's project is
so his motivations are to provide a
psychoanalytic analysis rather than a
strictly philosophical one
a orientation that is that is going to
come
out of his his own work as
a psychotherapist as uh somebody who's
who's there
in the world uh going through a lot of
different experiences
and the situation that he says he's
focusing on
is that of the black person
in the french antilles within
you know a particular sphere you can say
of the colonial world and
this is a rather unique one that i think
for
audiences in other places particularly
american audiences
you want to sort of adjust to to this
the french antilles uh has a different
orientation culturally in relation to
other areas that that would be you know
african or black right
and so there's a different dynamic
going on there that he's examining
but he tells us that this can apply much
more broadly and that's indeed why
black skin white mass is such an
influential work so let's look at the
specificity
of the antillean situation
he talks about this in a few different
points
in the work so very early on
he tells us here we go that
um he's talking about antilleans that
have gone
to france the the country that's their
you know they're they're essentially
incorporated within to the culture of
and he's already talking about the
nature of uh language and and how
important
that is and he says in every country of
the world there are climbers the ones
who forget who they are and in contrast
to them the ones who remember where they
came from so he's
sketching out a dynamic that is rather
universal
he says the antilles negro who goes home
from france expresses himself
in dialect if he wants to make it play
nothing has changed
he skips down a bit further and he says
in a more limited group when students
from the antilles meet in paris so now
he's talking about people
sort of transplanted out of their their
original place
into paris any by the way paris is not
just
problematic for people from the antilles
or other colonies
but also from other parts of france as
well he brings up leon
he says they have two possibilities they
can stand with the white world
and since they will speak french to be
able to confront certain problems and
incline to a certain degree
of universality in their conclusions or
to reject europe and cling together in
their dialect making themselves quite
comfortable in what we shall call the
umvelt the environment
of martinique by this i mean and this
applies particularly to my brothers of
the antilles
one when one of us tries in paris or any
other universal city to study a problem
seriously he's accused of
self-aggrandizement
and the surest way of cutting him down
is to remind him of the antilles by
exploding into dialect so
you're posed with a choice do you talk
in the universal language in this case
french
or do you talk in a dialect
in which case you know different
conditions get imposed on you
and this situation of having to deal
with these choices over and over again
is part of the antelian situation
he also talks much later on
in the work in the the discussion about
recognition
he says that the um it's not just this
or that and tillian who embodies the
neurotic
formation but all antilleans antillean
societies an erotic society
a society of comparison
hence we are driven back from the
individual back to the social structure
the martinican is and is not a
neurotic and this is coming up in a
discussion of of adler
who's an important psychoanalyst at the
time
and he's saying that there's something
it's not unique to the antilles
but there is something to the antillean
situation
earlier in the work he actually talks
about the lacanian mirror stage
and talks about an experiment where you
have somebody go through
a process of of uh thinking things
through and what a mirror image would be
and antilleans saying
that that person was neither black nor
white they had no color
so can you work from a situation like
that to
to describe more broadly
a situation and he says yes as a matter
of fact
the as he says the analysis must extend
more universally so
he he says on the basis of other studies
in my own personal observations
i want to show in terms of language why
the negro adopts such a position
peculiar to him with respect to european
languages
let me point out once more that the
conclusions i have reached
pertain to the french antilles but
then he goes on and he says at the same
time i'm not unaware that the same
behavior patterns obtained
in every race that has been subjected to
colonization now that is a very broad
thing that he's saying right there it
doesn't just refer to
black and white or french colonialism
he is saying any race any
people any situation of of you know
people within a society
that have been subjected to this this
this
research that i'm carrying out can apply
to them
later on in the work uh he he
brings this up again and explicitly
clarifies he says in the beginning i
wanted to confine
myself to the antilles and what's he
referring to
he's actually bringing up sart's
introduction to this anthology and then
a critique of it the critique says this
this anthology which puts antilleans
guanines senegalese and malagasy is on
the same footing
all of these are parts of the you could
say french colonial sphere
creates a deplorable confusion in the
way it states the cultural problem of
the oversea colonies by detaching them
from the historical and social reality
of each of them
from the national characteristics and
the varying conditions imposed on each
of them by imperialist
exploitation and oppression so you know
the question here is how do you take
into account
the specificity the particularity
of cultures that have had similar
dynamics imposed on them
but in different ways with different
histories with different results
and sometimes posed in relation to each
other
where the senegalese will be used as
you know enforcers the soldiers to
maintain
order by the french colonial government
against say
those in madagascar or those in the
french antilles
right or in other places so he goes on
and he says i wanted to confine myself
to the antilles
regardless of consequences dialectic
took the upper hand and i was compelled
to see that the antelian is first of all
a negro
nevertheless it would be impossible to
overlook the fact as he goes on
that there are negroes whose nationality
is different than their negro republic
so how can one
claim to have got hold of an essential
when such facts as these
demand one's recognition so he's posing
this this problem here
and we're going to come back to this in
in just a bit
this is a significant issue
how do you by doing something like
a psychoanalytic or perhaps you know
you could say a marxist critique
although he's you know he's a bit
distrustful
of the marxist in some respects or
something ethnographic
how do you extend from that to talking
about these dynamics more
generally so there's there's a double
consciousness and there's alternatives
you can say
that are rooted in in race
for fanon he goes on in this section and
he says
we we can't overlook the fact there are
negroes whose nationality is belgian
french english different worlds you know
the belgian congo
is not the same thing as english
nigeria is not the same thing as
uh you know french senegal and each of
them
has their own uh you know processes of
development and ways in which
colonialism
was imposed i mean with belgium and the
congo you in effect have genocide being
committed for
the purpose of uh gathering
rubber so he says there are also negro
republics
how can one claim to have gotten hold of
an essential
when these demand one's recognition the
truth is that the negro race has been
scattered it can no longer claim
unity but there is a sort of unity that
comes with it with with the dynamic he
says
in the universal situation of the negro
there's an ambiguity which is resolved
in his concrete existence
what is that he says against all the
arguments i have cited i come back to
one fact
wherever he goes the negro remains
a negro so it's it's a matter
really of what is imposed upon
one by others by virtue
of these racial markers and and you know
the cultural situation
that goes with it um so there's a double
consciousness
of this and he he goes on and talks
about this as well
a little bit later on he says that
again picking up sardi says one can
understand why sart views the adoption
of a marxist position by black poets
as the logical conclusion of negro hood
in effect what happens is this as soon
as i begin to recognize
that the negro is the symbol of sin i
catch myself hating the negro but then i
recognize that i'm the negro
there's two ways out of this conflict
there's a dilemma
being posed either i ask others to pay
no attention to my skin
or else i want them to be aware of it i
then try to find value for what is bad
since i've unthinkingly conceded the
black man is the color of evil
and he calls this a neurotic situation
in which i'm compelled to choose an
unhealthy conflictual situation
fed on fantasies and he says i have one
other solution
to rise above this absurd drama others
have staged around me to reject
the two terms that are equal and
unacceptable and through one human being
to reach out for the
universal so once again we see this
interplay of the particular
in this case the individual and the
universal
so what what is the universal that we
can talk about here
well part of it is a universal
situation of racism
exploitation domination carried out
and fanon has some very
useful things to say about this
he says he's criticizing this this
manoni who is talking about madagascar
and he says
that monony says that colonial
exploitation is not the same as other
forms of exploitation
colonial racialism is different than
other forms of racialism
and fanon goes on and he says he speaks
of phenomenology psychoanalysis of human
brotherhood
so fanon is is sort of positioning
himself
in relation to manoni as somebody who's
coming from the same
background of of you know useful
approaches and then he says
we would be happier if these terms are
taken on a more concrete
quality form more concrete quality
meaning paying
closer attention to particularity
he says all forms of exploitation
resemble
one another this is fun owns position
they all seek the source of their
necessity and some edict of a biblical
nature
all forms of exploitation are identical
because all of them are applied against
the same object
man and then he goes on and he says
colonial racism is no different from any
other
racism it's it's not fundamentally
different in fact what's going on here
is the result of a historical
contingency we could say a little bit
later on
towards the end of the the work he says
the negro problem does not resolve
itself into the problem of negroes
living among white men but rather of
negroes exploited enslaved despised by a
colonialist
capitalist society and here's the key
point that is only
accidentally white
so we're we could go on a little bit
more and we will in just a moment but we
should hesitate on some of those
matters um it's it's a historical
contingency
that europeans wound up being the
dominant race in you know
also in former colonies as well
and exploiting in some cases
exterminating
and subjugating other races
in fact hardening the concept
of race as well in the process
it could have been other groups as well
and this could be extended to other
dominant
you know ethnic or nationalities or
whatever we want to think about so this
could be applied
to say han chinese domination
in you know communist china of other
nationalities this could be
applied in many other cases wherever you
have
as he's saying
[Music]
being exploited enslaved despised by a
colonialist
capitalist society we would have this
this going on
now does that make it no longer an
issue of black and white well it's it's
all just a universal human dynamic no
the historical contingency matters
because that does determine thing
for people and we can say that there's a
recognition
on fanon's part of different
universalities
in the past and in the present and
here's where we get to
another dilemma that arises he says
you wonder mr solomon what you would do
if you had
800 000 negroes in france because for
you there's a problem the problem of the
increase of negroes the problem of the
black peril
but the martinican is a frenchman he
wants to remain part of the french union
he asks only one thing he wants the
idiots and the exploiters to give him
the chance to live
like a human being i can imagine myself
lost submerged in a white flood composed
of men like serger aragon
i should like nothing better and he goes
on and he says
i do not feel i should be abandoning my
personality by marrying a european
if my children are suspected it will be
simply because society will not have
changed
so we've got this double consciousness
going on
and a recognition on fun owns part that
there's not just one universality but
different ways of understanding and
living out universality
um lastly there there's also diversity
and distinctions we could say in black
situations but also the possibility
of developing understanding so some
examples of this uh distinction that we
can say
um he says it's obvious
that this in this quest for
disalienation by a doctor of medicine
born in guadalupe can only
can be understood only by recognizing
motivations basically different from
those of the negro laborer building the
port
facilities in abuja in the first case
the alienation is almost an intellectual
character
insofar as he conceives as european
culture as means of stripping himself of
his race
he becomes alienated in the second case
it is a question of a victim of a system
based on the exploitation of a given
race by another
on the contempt in which a given branch
of humanity is held by a form of
civilization
that pretends to superiority and he says
i
i wouldn't ask those who are not in my
situation
in fact a privileged situation to share
in my conclusions i can understand where
they're coming from
and so there's this incredible diversity
within we can say
black situations colonialism is not
exactly the same
in every case one can't identify oneself
as the universal
black subject with all others he talks
about that at a number of other points
in in the work that it doesn't
actually help anybody to to do that um
we also we already talked about the um
universal situation of the negro that
wherever he goes
the person remains a negro and then he
continues in that
that passage thing in some countries the
negroes entered into the culture
it would be impossible to ascribe too
much importance in the way in which
white children establish contact with
the reality
of the negro and here he's talking about
the united states and saying
the situation is is different for
uh you know a segregationist united
states than it is for antilleans than it
is for senegalese
than it is for uh people in sub-saharan
uh other other parts of sub-saharan
black africa
say in east africa right so this is this
is an important set of distinctions but
here's something worth ending on the
approach that fenona is taking overall
relies on the capacity for understanding
outside of the sphere
of our lived experience and being able
to take
into account others experience
so he he goes on and he says i sincerely
believe a subjective experience can be
understood by others
it would give me no pleasure to announce
that the black problem is my problem and
mine alone and it's up to me to study it
but that doesn't mean that everybody's
automatically
as open as accessible as transparent
and so he's faulting you know some some
previous scholars for
not having been we could say thoughtful
enough for not having
here he goes he mr manoni has not tried
to feel himself
into the despair of the man of color
confronting the white man
and so he says i've made it a point to
convey the misery of the black man
physically and effectively i've not
wished to be objective
that would be dishonest it's not
possible for me to be objective but that
doesn't mean that it's pure
subjectivity or that only one's lived
experience
matters a little bit later
in the work he he says that
what we do with phenomenology and for
the kind of psychoanalysis that fanon is
doing phenomenology is really central
is less the study of a large number of
instances than the intuitive and deep
understanding
of a few individual cases
so again we have the issue of the
particularity
and universality can one as fanon is
doing
begin with the situation of a particular
exploited and alienated people
those of his you know the french
antilles
and then generalize to how to understand
colonialism exploitation capitalism
racism all these things that are
connected together historically
the answer is yes there's no one simple
single straightforward way and i do want
to end by invoking that word dialectic
this means that there's always going to
have to be
a back and forth involved in it and that
no particular work including this one
will be
the last word on both you know the
universal situation
and the particular situation on the
ground
you